so dinner yeah we met many years ago
mm-hmm I photographed you and we just
trying to each other on the streets so
tell me what's new since the last time I
digress which is about seven eight nine
years ago I'm clean now and been clean
so the drug that you were using was well
it was called crack cocaine
really I couldn't even tell you it's
been quite some time a few years is the
temptation still there no Betty wait
does he bothers me to see other people
doing him if I can get clean they can -
it's not a problem what I can't stop
doing is smoking cigarettes well I can
but it's harder to stop those didn't it
is drugs what do you what do you think
keeps all these people I don't know
probably things like if they were in a
program like a rehab or whatever things
had to come out like a family member
dying or Eurasian yeah
I don't know having to do things that
happen when they were a kid being
traumatized things like that more than
likely or there's some people who just
like you yeah
driven to self-destruct exactly they
just there's nothing that's gonna get
away nothing they won't let anything
exactly along
exactly then they don't some of them
don't realize that's what they're doing
they're theirs they're self-destructing
it they don't realize that that's
exactly yeah they would yeah they think
you're do you the crazy one get away
from me like I look at I look at them
I'm like oh my god that used to be me
yeah and it makes me a little sick to my
stomach
yeah I think once you've gotten clean of
it then you see the picture very exactly
you see what you used to be and it's
horrible it's horrible when you went
yeah like you just said we're in the
middle of it you don't see it you see
yourself as like
you you glamorize yourself you know I'm
saying you look good you talk good you
act good you dress good you all of that
and really is awful
seeing you before and seeing you now you
look up here your energy is much better
thank you your your weight here I didn't
clear thinking I can just remember all
of this Daniel yesterday you've improved
in every industry really well I think
you look so much comfier better thank
you I'm trying I can't
I wanted to give up but that would be
giving up on myself be giving up on my
family lobby with everything me giving
up on everything and I can't do that
drugs in the first place my family I
hate to say that that's always sounds
bad I know but if I was I was
traumatized as a child from age 4 until
I was 13 a lot of different people I'd
rather not get into it it's pretty bad
okay
I was I was molested I was being
I was molested by my brother first he
was the very first one at four years old
he penetrated my diaper and he
penetrated me with his thumb and now
we're on for a couple years and he
dropped it off he didn't die or anything
but he stopped doing it and I had by
stepfathers that took his place separate
ones yeah at different times
periodically my mother was a blackout
drunk a Hatton drug thyratron
whatever kind of drunk there is she was
it so she never knew that I was being
molested by my stepfather's every one of
them did and I was I had two sisters but
I would see only girl left at home so
because I'm the baby girl yeah
yeah until I was 13 I left I went away
because my mother had the audacity to
tell me if anything happened if anything
happened to you she knows damn well
there did there was also two other men
that I don't even know their names they
were babies back when I was a child
okay
if I if anything happened to me I wanted
to tell I do I'm a hoarder her according
to her I'm a [ __ ]
get out of my house and she literally
kicked me out of the house at 13 yeah so
I went ahead met at third
and I've been on my own ever since where
you going 13 all over is their travel
thank these redraw Alabama
finding you
in Jefferson County and I grew up in
Shelby County and Chelsea little town
called Chelsea that's where I went to
high school and everything to there is
called Chelsea high school at smarts a
high school but it's all is elementary
preschool elementary and all that anyway
I just
god rest her soul my sister Victoria she
was the first person ever put a pipe in
my mouth for a needle in my arm when I
was 12
[Music]
and it released a lot of the pain out of
me however I don't blame her anymore she
because I'm the one they kept doing I
did that I I'm not mad at her or nothing
anymore however the people at this man
named Don he's a counselor after
Hillsman treatment facility which I
graduated from also I'm an alumni from
there he told me no I need to still
blame her
because if it wasn't for her I would
have never started he doesn't know that
he doesn't know that I could have did it
on my own but regardless I kept doing it
I kept putting apart my mouth I kept
putting the needle in my arm I did that
she was murdered at 23 she was shot up
with enough cocaine poisoning to kill
two people and that was back in Alabama
that was one of the things that luckily
I was here but he it still tore me up
pretty bad because I was really really
close to her really close to her my
father was murdered when I was three and
I watched that happen he was shot in the
back with a double-barrel shotgun there
was a hole in his back as big as the
baseball as he was breathing you could
hear the gravel going out of his back I
was laying on top of it he just from
from the impact of the shot in his back
he hit me look you know the old cars he
got that little push button button on
the handle and it opens the old car yes
he and from the impact of the shot it
caused his thumb I guess the reflex to
open the door where I was pounding on
the window calling his name daddy got
daddy and I fell out on top of you
that's how I know what it sounds the
gravel going in that'll be back how
itself and how much do you think you're
the environment you grew up in played a
part in your addition I mean all of it
all of it now that I'm
I don't know how to put that yeah
I don't know how to put it I really
you've got yeah there's nothing I can
say yeah you're right thank you
that part I should be dead so the skin
condition that it's improved it has it's
like when he gets hotter though and I my
body temperature rises I'll break out
more it's from being I broke out on me
at first when I was 14
it's called neurofibromatosis it's not
regulated in the ball of nerves at the
bottom of my spine there is a disorder
and there and the doctors were unable to
locate it when I was younger I also went
to a dermatologist and he said it was a
deficiency of vitamin A I would spend
all sorts of vitamin A it didn't work
okay
and like I said a few minutes ago it's
not drug related
it is a nerve disorder in in my ball of
nerves at the bottom of my spine yes
it's caused from being traumatized like
I was from age 4 even until now but I am
doing so much better yeah this is
looking better I'm looking better I'm
feeling better I am better
so how many years reason hey am i used
for food I'm 50 years old right I know I
look 90 but um and I used for 42 of
those years yeah if I can do it anybody
can do it anybody I don't care who you
are or what you're doing you can stop it
you know you can't stop it look at me